[Music]
hi my name is Jacob mcale I'm a
scientist at stress mark biosciences
we're located in Victoria British
Columbia Canada and we are a bioreagents
company and I'm going to tell you today
about novel tools for drug Discovery in
neurodegenerative diseases that we've
been developing for the past uh several
years now
now Alzheimer's and Parkinson's diseases
are the most common neurodegenerative
disorders Alzheimer's disease is the six
leading cause of death in the US likely
closer to third in those age 65 plus so
this is a massive problem and and
despite
significant impact and and massive
investment in research a lot of clinical
trials no definitive cures are
known these diseases are both
characterized by the presence of plaques
in the brain and these consist of
protein aggregates which include key
proteins alphascan particular in
Parkinson's and ameloid beta and too in
Alzheimer's
disease now Alpha nucle and toao and
amid beta share a common pathological
mechanism whereas these relatively
disordered monomers form these toxic
iggers and these really hydrophobic
fibral that deposit in these plaques in
the brains of of these patients and here
at stress marker goal is to produce
active pathology inducing Aggregates
such as these iggers and fibral in vitro
for use as reagents for disease model
development to really accelerate
Alzheimer's disease Parkinson's disease
drug
Discovery now starting with Parkinson's
disease it's characterized by alphascan
aggregation so again we have this this
normal native
alphascan uh fairly disordered in
solution it does form some order when
it's on membranes uh but through through
this this pathological process from
delers fibral and these fibral deposit
in what are called Louis bodies and
there also significant evidence for
transmission between different sort of
infected uh deposited plaque neurons to
one
another and an important part of this is
the presence of this this phosphorated
Serene 129 on these fibral so as these
are deposited uh they become more more
phosphorated at this this 129 position
of Alpha slean and that's actually a
Hallmark uh in Louis body Aggregates for
Parkinson's
Disease this going to be important
because it's a way we we demonstrate
pathology Within These disease models
from some of our recombinant materials
we use to induce Parkinson's like
disease so we've generated several types
of uclean pre-formed fibral in vitro uh
so here you can see the uh fairly pure
protein on the left and and these fibral
we've generated under temm in the middle
panel and we can actually track the
formation of these fibral in vitro doing
a tht binding assay so as this tht
molecule binds to these more hydrophobic
ameloid fibral it actually shifts its
its fluorescent Spectra and basically as
you get more and more fibral forming you
get more and more tht binding and you
get an increase in in fluorescent signal
now it's important to note these reent
uh We've expressed this Al coli and then
fibred it in a test tube basically so
there's no phosphorilation present
because eoli can't post translationally
modify these with phosphorilation so
going into the experiments there's none
of that phosphoserine 129 and and
that'll be something we're looking for
to represent a Parkinson's disease model
and we've been able to do this uh
preformed fibral in both human mouse and
rat variants of of Alas nucleon and all
of them seed monomers into fibros and
betro so in the first model here um we
have these alphascan preform fibral on
neuroblastoma cells uh so these were
initially isolated from a Cancer and and
they're commonly used to study um
neurogenerative diseases they're they're
neuronlike cells and what you'll notice
uh especially in the the middle two
panels here at Time Zero our phosphos
129 it appears to be a bit of a signal
so this is using antibodies staining
these these fixed cells um at time zero
here um and you'll see there's a little
bit of phosphos 129 signal that's
actually just uh We've run some controls
and that's just due to The Binding of
our secondary antibody which is is the
fluorescent one um to the ER region so
that signal really is not there after
three hours you can see a robust
increase in this phosphoserine 129
signal so that has to be occurring
within the cells as the the f we're
adding don't have a phosphor seran 129
so we reducing that that pathological
aspect of the disease here are 2f1
antibod so that's an antibody we have
that's anti- agregate so it will bind to
these fibral you'll notice that also has
a robust response even within within
three hours after addition of these pffs
to these neuroblastoma cells we see a
massive increase in in aggregat so we're
both recreating the phosphoserine 129
pathology and and inducing aggregation
of the endogenous fibral uh here within
3 hours so very quick robust model um of
Parkinson's disease in in cell
culture now we also wanted to
demonstrate the actual transfer of these
preformed fibral between different
neurons and the experiment we designed
here was a fluorescently labeled to this
BF 555 uh fluorescent tag on these
preformed fibral we incubate ated them
with gfp expressing neuroblastoma cells
so they've been differentiated for8 days
they're glowing green they're expressing
gfp and we're adding the the fibral to
them after 48 Hours of incubation of
these we then um wash away the free
fibral and then trypsinize these so any
floating around free fibral is going to
be gone it's only going to be the
internalized fibral remaining in these
neuroblastoma
cells and then these are added on to8
day differentiated ipscs so these are
differentiated to form neurons these are
human ipscs um and we're going to be
looking at a purple color here uh
for tubulin and essentially what we see
here in this image is after 14 days this
this sort of coold culture uh is imaged
and what you'll see in green these are
the gfp expressing neuroblastoma cells
you'll see some red in there that is is
the actual tagged fibral uh but what
you'll also see is is when you look at
the the tubulin rich
ipscs you'll see that the the red fibral
have actually transferred into these
ipsc cells so evidence of direct
transfer from these
neuroblastoma uh inoculated cells into
these ipsc cells which is is pretty cool
to see this this
transmission then we have actual Mouse
models using these pffs so here we're
looking at phosphoserine 129 staining in
a mouse
brain after 30 days um so a single
unilateral injection to Dorsal strum and
you'll see on the top here looking at
monomer there's there's really no
staining at the two concentrations
tested when you look at the preformed
fibral at both concentrations you will
see that darker staining and especially
at the higher 5 microgram injection you
actually see it it
transmitting to the other hemisphere of
the brain uh which is pretty exciting so
these pffs have have proven
functionality in in generating
Parkinson's disease models both in
neuroblastoma cells and and ipscs as
well as actual Mouse
models and just a reminder um so that's
the PFF side of life uh the igamer
species there's evidence out there that
this is actually the more toxic species
and this is what should be uh targeted
therapeutically so we also want to be
able to recreate those
and for alphascan we've been able to
generate these kinetically stable algers
in vitro um so you can see here on the
left panel this is a native gel normally
Alpha nucleon on Native gel runs between
75 and 50 kilodaltons and you'll see it
runs above 250 kiltons there in the
middle we have an SEC trace and we've
actually been able to
uh freeze thaw these and incubate them
for 37 degrees for up to 14 days we've
tested and they don't actually lose
their aleric structure um so you can see
that there's a small amount of monomer
within the prep but the majority of it
is igamer and stays o ligr and elutes
the the size we would expect of an algr
and on the right that is so these
globular structures rather than these
longer fibr forms um for ligar and the
important thing to note here is these
are generated in a native state so
there's no inducer inhibitor there's no
dopamine there's no um other materials
added to force them into this it's it's
just them alone in an oomer
State and it's important to note too
that these iggers are structurally
different than the fibrils they're not
just little pieces of fibral that have
broken off the actual secondary
structure of these is quite different uh
and they are all also soluble so this is
far uvcd and and basically it gives you
an idea of of the relative amount of
alpha helical beta sheet disordered
structure and what you'll notice here is
thegamers tend to be much more Alpha
helical whereas the fibrils of course
are are higher beta sheet that amid type
structure that the tht binds to that we
track during those those seaing assays
so there are fundamental differences in
the structure of these iggers and fibral
um they're not just pieces of each other
they're they're distinct
so we then took these um and tested them
for against primary rat dopaminergic
neurons so here we're looking at uh our
control and our treated primary uh Rat
neurons and we're standing with with map
two for dopaminergic neurons and we're
also standing for phosphoserine 129 so
map 2 is is in red phosphoserine 129 is
in
green and so you'll see anywhere there's
yellow which is indicated in arrows just
for for clarity overlap between
dopaminergic neurons and phosphoserine
129 so these non phosphorilated
kinetically stable ligers are added to
culture and um you'll see clearly that
there is phosphoserine 129 pathology
induced and quantifying this so again
this was 11 days after um addition these
were these were fixed and and imaged and
look at both survival so the actual
toxicity of these iggers as well as
quantifying that phosphos in 129 I
displayed on the previous slide you'll
see at at certain higher concentrations
the kinetically stable ligers are toxic
so there's a reduced survival of these
neurons and that's Quantified by map 2
and nuclei and and basically cell
counting of these at the end of the
experiment versus the control a monomer
has no effect on toxicity these
kinetically stable leers do um and then
quantifying the phosphoserine 129 on the
right here you'll
see at as the as the concentration of
iggers increases you get a a greater
amount of phosphoserine 129
detected so in summary of of our current
Parkinson's disease models we have
alphascan iggers and fibral that we
generate in vro are able to actually
induce this Parkinson's phosphoserine
129 as well as aggregation in cellular
and rodent models of disease which is
pretty exciting for disease um for
studying disease and and studying
different Inhibitors potentially of this
process and we do also have some
behavioral changes that we've observed
in mice I don't have time to talk about
it today and and it's to be published um
but keep an eye out for
that now looking at Alzheimer's disease
so Alzheimer's disease is characterized
by both to and and amid beta Aggregates
and I'm going to talk about the to
portion of this first so we have to
normally in cells is going to stabilize
microtubules and again we have an
instance where in solution it's a very
flexible soluble molecule and through
aggregation it forms both iggers and and
fibrils and eventually these neuro
fibral are Tangles that are found in in
the brain of of Alzheimer's disease
patients
and we've been able to generate several
forms of tow preformed fibral in vitro
so there are several different um splice
variants and and isoforms and lengths
and core of the phf versus full length
material and and we've been able to
generate quite a few of these um for
example the towel Kine fragment uh which
is induced with Heparin so this is a
molecule that helps it fiiz uh we also
have the full length towel that we've
expressed in bacula virus which is hyper
phosphorated which I'll talk about in a
bit uh and this smaller to DGA fragment
so sort of the core of the fibral uh
which I think is going to be critical
for a lot of research going on as
there's quite a bit of evidence now that
this is most closely mimicking
Alzheimer's disease uh T
fibral so starting with the the tal K so
this is a Hein induced towel uh when
this is injected into a transgenic towel
Mouse so it it has the
p301l mutation uh we do see it induces
pathology so here we're looking at
phosphoserine 202 205 as opposed to for
Parkinson's Disease we were looking at
Alpha phosphine 129 now we're looking at
too phosphos seran 202 205 standing with
an antibody and we see nine weeks after
injection we do get robust pathology
this 202 205 again this is not
phosphorated going in it's actually
inducing this uh physiological
pathological process of of increasing
this phosphorilation which is present in
in these neurofibrillar
Tangles and again always trying to work
towards the most relevant disease model
the thing that most closely mimics human
disease and in human disease when when
those how molecules come off of
microtubules they eventually become
hyper phosphor for related and and
that's one of the drivers of sort of
this oligomerization fibrilization and
so we wanted to generate hyper
phosphorated towel and we were able to
do this and it actually fiiz on its own
without the addition of Heparin so
that's removing another variable from
the experiment um and hopefully getting
closer towards what is really happening
in in a human brain uh to recreate in a
disease model so over 30 sites on on
this tow ex best in bacular virus sf9 so
so for those of you who don't know um
the bacular virus sf9 system is an
insect cell system so it's eukariotic
system which allows us to produce
proteins with post transational
modifications and this hyper
phosphorilation allows it to fibril on
its own without the addition of
Hein then uh looking at this this to
dgae fragment um so this will actually
form fibral on its own it's expressed in
eoli so it doesn't have uh the
phosphorilation that's that's something
we're also working on uh but in in our
hands this actually most closely mimics
ad isolated phfs so there's some
literature that come out recently that's
actually looked at the crym structures
of these things and and come to a
similar conclusion with this DGA
fragment that it actually most closely
looks like these par helical filaments
that are isolated from actual
Alzheimer's disease patient brains and
our hands here we have uh compared to
the the the ad isolated
phfs against
primary Mouse hippocampal neurons after
seven days so these are treated and then
they are fixed with hdta which removes
all soluble TOA
species and then basically the t49
antibody which is a most specific to
antibody so this isn't going to
recognize this human DGA fragment we've
added it will only recognize the most
material that is not soluble that's
deposited because of the fixation method
it removes anything that's soluble and
what you'll see here and that's that's
Quantified on the left on the right here
t49 in in yellow you'll see that there
are actually endogenous Mouse tow
Aggregates induced by the addition of of
these human DGA pffs and you can see it
Quantified there on the left compared to
um the Alzheimer's dis isolated material
which also induces a similar effect and
compared to some of the other fibral and
the heon induced ones we we didn't see
that effect so we we feel like we're uh
on the right track to developing the
most disease like preform fibral
here now looking at the other side so um
the amid beta side of things so you'll
see essentially this amul beta peptide
is is normally in this this large
transmembrane protein uh the peptide
ends up being cleaved off and then it
Aggregates into iggers and and fibrils
and and deposits in these amid
plaques and we've been able to generate
from a synthetic peptide in the lab both
algers and fibral of this ameloid beta 1
to 42 peptide so here's the the temm
from left to right we have monomers so
there's there's not much material
visible there iggers these nice round
globular structures and then on fibral
on the right these
elongated um ameloid
fibral and here basically showing the
same thing um on AFM so we have the
monomers ligers and fibral and on a
western blot so SDS gel um Western
blotted with the 610 antibody which just
sees all ameloid beta essentially um you
can see a very distinct signal on a even
even after SDS treatment and Western
blotting monomers run
at you know about five kons the peptides
around four and a half and then for the
iggers you'll see a bit of a dmer trimer
signal as well as the smear um for the
algers at at larger molecular weights
and for the fibral that's even higher
and we also get a deposit in the actual
well of the gel so a unique signal on a
western blot for these different
materials and that translates into
actual toxicity so again looking at
primary rat cortical neurons and here
we're just looking at toxicity and
you'll see on on the left there uh
compared to control the the monomer and
vehicle control there's there's no
difference
here after 11 days and or 14 days sorry
in the middle panel we have increasing
concentrations of of our iggers same
concentrations tested as monomer and
what you'll see is a dose dependent
toxicity of the iggers as well as on the
right of the fibral so they are due to
their unique structure inducing toxicity
whereas monomer peptide on its own is is
not having that effect so there there is
a unique um structure
there and so interestingly more recently
um Beyond mul beta 1 to 42 peptide which
has had a lot of clinical
development um a lot of failed clinical
development there is this pyroglutamate
3 ameloid beta so um essentially what
happens here and you can see a schematic
on the right is the normal a beta 142
peptide is truncated by proteases and
then um it's Modified by this glutamin
cyclas which basically it cuts off the
first the first two amino acids are cut
off and then the the third glutamate is
cyclized and this increases its
hydrophobicity and and
neurotoxicity and it's the presence of
this modified amid beta peptide in
plaques increases as Alzheimer's disease
progresses so while many a81 to 42 the
Fink peptide targeting drugs whether
they're targeting the ligers the fibral
have failed there is still clinical
development going on for this sort of um
more degraded modified um higher
presence in later Alzheimer's disease
species of of this amid beta
and recently we've been able to generate
fibrils again from a synthetic peptide
so this pyroglutamate three amid beta 3
to 42 peptide um again on the left a
unique fibral signal compared to monomer
so we get that sort of deposit in in the
well of the gel and then here we have uh
on the right temm and AFM images of
these nice long fibral uh interestingly
these these do seem to Aggregate and
these fibral more rapidly than the
unmodified amul beta 1 to 42 in our
hands um and no data yet today but we do
have toxicity comparisons uh underway
for both the 1: 42 versus the um
pyroglutamate 3 a
beta so in summary of our Alzheimer's
disease models tal fibral generated in
vitro do induce Alzheimer's phosphos
seran 202 205 pathology and transgenic
mice
although some of these novel Heparin
free fibral May better mimic disease so
the bacula virus expressed full length
towel with the hyper phosphorilation
that that Aggregates on its own as well
as this DGA fragment that appears to
more closely mimic the pathology of an
Alzheimer's uh patient isolated uh parad
helical
filament and uh amulite beta iggers and
fibral do exhibit dose dependent
toxicity in in primary neurons
although some of the clinical failures
of of that Target have led um us to
develop and and Pharma to Target these
uh pyro AA 3 to 42 constructs which
we're excited to see what the toxicity
looks like for
these so finally and and most
interesting some of the newest stuff
we've developed here um actually
involves cross seating so we've been
able to generate these
co-polymer Alpha ccle and to fi so these
fibral actually have units of alphascan
and to within them and will seed each
other uh so here and this is this is
amuno TM and what we've labeled are a
gold conjugated anti- Alphas nucleon so
six nanometers that's the smaller
smaller units um smaller black dots on
the image here and then an anti-t 12
nanometer conjugated antibod those are
the larger black circles and you can see
within the same strand you have both of
these individual units um and this has
been done before so this was first
demonstrated back in 2003 um and
literature has suggested that this cross
seating is occurring possibly within
amid inclusions so very interesting to
see where um this cross
seating concept goes um for Parkinson's
and Alzheimer's therapeutic development
um as we understand these things things
more and
more so uh future directions we want to
demonstrate behavioral deficits in mice
uh for both the Parkinson's um and
Alzheimer's disease models and and we do
have for Parkinson's Mouse model some um
behavioral deficits which will be
published hopefully soon uh we are
currently looking at actually looking at
these recombinant Aggregates in
microglia so how are pffs being taken up
by micro
um processed by microa and possibly how
are they toxic to microa or basically
what happens after that so looking
Beyond just just
neurons and then we want to uh
eventually expand this characterization
of these different PFS and iggers uh and
more sort of human disease
representative models such as human
neuronal ipscs and and organoids so we
can better mimic true human disease um
outside of uh sort of most models are
transgenic
models so with that I'd like to thank
everyone at stress mark um and our
collaborators and C so they're all
listed within this presentation um Who
provided the data for us they've been
integral to a lot of our work um and if
you have any additional questions or
just want more information please visit
stressmarq and TTR and are developing um
TDP 43 pffs as well so thank
you